there are new developments in the case
of a wrong-way accident involving an
American in England that we've been
following very closely here 19 year old
Harry Dunne was on a motorcycle when he
was hit by a car driven by an cyclist
she's a wife out of an American official
in Britain MTS tyub is outside the US
Embassy in London MTS what are we
learning now from British police good
morning well in a remarkable development
we are hearing from British police that
they will travel to the u.s. to
interview and cyclists the American
woman at the heart of this extraordinary
diplomatic dispute that's only getting
bigger now an cyclist was the subject of
a press conference overnight where
police say she requested to be
interviewed by investigators and they
say they'll be speaking with her under
essentially the u.k of equivalent of her
Miranda rights now the American was last
questioned by UK investigators on the
28th of August that's just the day after
the fatal accident it's also when police
learned that she may have had diplomatic
immunity now in September 16th
authorities became aware she had left
Britain possibly in a US Air Force plane
but it really wasn't until 10 days later
that the Dunn family were told she had
returned to the United States
now britain's Foreign Secretary is
questioning whether the diplomatic
immunities to coulis used to leave the
UK should be guaranteed for the 16,000
or so American personnel and their
families at the airbase where sakru's
lived and near to where she killed done
in that head-on collision Harry Don's
death sparked an extraordinary campaign
for justice that saw his family traveled
to the US meet the President and nearly
and Sue coolest now I've just gotten off
the phone with Harry Dunn's parents they
say that this is the step in the right
direction but they say until unsecure
astiz here in the UK and turns herself
in this isn't over yet
Anthony all right MTS tyub in London
some movement in that case finally thank
you